l'espoir renaît
mais rien est acquis le lundi 11 mai le
nouvel horizon à faire aux français en
confinement
jusque là les règles de ce confinement
doivent être respectés de façon stricte
a dit le président emmanuel macron le
lundi 11 mai ne sera possible que si
nous continuons d'être civique
responsable de respecter les règles et
que si la propagation du virus a
effectivement continuer à ralentir
c'est un discours en pâtit sobre et
humble qu'a prononcé le président de la
république - guerrier mais empreint de
vocabulaire évocateur de la première
guerre mondiale la france a tenu règles
plus a fait face ernement elle doit
continuer continuer d'être respecté le
président a reconnu de nombreuses rails
dans la réponse de l'état
le moment soyons honnêtes a révélé des
failles des insuffisances comme tous les
pays du monde
nous avons manqué de blues de gants de
gel hydroalcoolique
nous n'avons pas pu distribuer autant de
masques que nous l'aurions voulu pour
nos soignants dès le 11 mai chaque
français aura accès à un masque de
protection légère premier thil et tous
ceux qui présentent des symptômes seront
testés
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
ce sont les crèches les écoles et lycées
qui en premier devraient ouvrir leurs
portes
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marquées en revanche les lieux de
grands rassemblements resteront fermés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
restaurants cinémas festival emmanuel
macron promesses et secteur durement
touché des aides supplémentaires pour
affronter les interdits dont ils sont
frappés le 11 mai la france entrera dans
une nouvelle phase la répéter l'onu
rendre une nouvelle phase qui la berra
transformé à jamais sachons dans ce
moment sortir des sentiers battus des
idéologies et nous réinventer moi le
premier
ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada paris